Looks like Reza, I don't think he'll be able to join.
To.
No problem. So, we can make it quick. So, since in the previous connect, we discussed about one shift replacement, and this is something that we are considering. Also, we spoke about the training plan for the engineers for
Yeah.
Mhm.
for their skill development. Although you shared the topics and we shared the time duration it will take, however, the weekly cadence on this training, it would stretch that training to close to six or seven months.
which would not be as effective as we expect it to be. So given that timeline and the time slot that I shared with you, that if we can have it like every day, provided 30 minutes from there, from the lunch timings of the engineers and 30 minutes from
Yes.
Their regular shift timings, so that the business continuity is also there, and you just would get, you know, enough time to eat their food.
Kip.
Yeah, I personally I'm hesitant to cut into their actual lunchtime with this.
Ultimately, this is a decision for Reza to make.
My thoughts would be...
They're already starting, essentially.
The default shifts are essentially already an hour longer than our normal technician shifts. So taking half an hour from that, if you want to do it on a daily cadence, that makes sense to me. But my personal view is that it's better off to be taken from the beginning or the end of their shift.
Just.
Okay.
Or maybe somewhere in the middle so that all of their shifts can can so we can use the same slot for all for all the all four people or how many people we have or let's say 5 or whatever.
So they can all be on the same group call, group session perhaps, and...
like an hour a day, that's fine from my perspective, because it improves their understanding of systems, their knowledge base, and so on.
But, yeah, again, although it will be as a decision for...
the frequency of it, the cadence of it, and when it should happen, right? From my perspective, no, they should have their normal full lunch, because a rested mind is a better mind, right? It's less likely to make mistakes. Of course, and
I appreciate it.
So, if we can take some time out of their, you know, out of their normal job, that would be my preference, actually, because it's a long-term investment into their into their ability to do it well.
Yes.
That's just my perspective, but again, I can't make this decision. This would be ultimately up to Reza.
Okay, so we would expect results response on that email and...
Probably, Arkadi, if you could, you know, just connect with results so that he can let us know what what he is, what he what he is, what he prefers for the training slots that we can accommodate it, as you mentioned that you prefer beginning of the shift or end of the shift, so...
Yeah.
I know towards the end of the shift, engineers are more into triaging the tickets, that the call flow is less, and you know...
most of the concerns and issues are dealt towards the beginning of or mid of the day already. So they would have a decent amount of time to focus on the training. The probability of them not attending the training would be less significantly if they do it in the beginning of the day.
Agreed, and we can also, because Jasper's shift ends at 4, and...
Yes.
If, if, okay, this was gonna be another topic of discussion, let's say Jimmy moves to...
to the 11 to 8 P.m. shift, and then she's moved to the 9 to 9 to 8, sorry, 9 to 6 shift, right? Then we can probably find a slot somewhere around 3 P.m. or 2 P.m. when all or all five are going to be available at the same time. It's towards the end of Jas's shift.
Yep.
So, it's towards the beginning of the shift of the other, or if it's in the middle of their shift somewhere, so...
Key.
Because it's such a large spread of time between when Jasp begins and when, you know, Jimmy and Vanch end presently, it's...
We kind of have to consider.
Is the middle point maybe better, or because what is the middle point for those is is the endpoint for for for Jasmine, yeah?
Yeah, you're right.
So I think 330 Eastern or 3 Eastern would be the best time because Jas would be completing his shift and rest of the engineers would be in their shift timings and they can accommodate the time to attend the training.
And also, the training sessions will be recorded, so if for any reason they have to drop off to take an incoming call, they can rebuild their training to, you know, get up to speed.
Yeah.
That's good.
Hey, that's a good idea, yeah.
Yeah.
So, that's essentially without, unfortunately, we can't make that decision, but I'm sure either by email or by next week, after we discussed with him, he can let you guys know. The other typical discussion is moving Jimmy next week to the...
Kour.
Shiv presently occupied by Vanch as our second evening technician, working together with another technician who's already been in that role for several months.
Key.
The ideal would be to move Bench back to 9 to 6, or even if he is amenable, moving to 7, 7 to 4.
It's the from my perspective, yeah, yes sir, that's right. We can we can check with him what's more convenient for him, because to me there's not much much difference there, as long as...
7 to 4 Eastern.
Okay.
You know, as long as we can move Jimmy to the latest shift, then we have that covered with him and another technician.
Sure. So you want this change to happen from next week or?
From next week, that's right, yeah.
Okay, so Jimmy would be doing one shift, that's going to be 10 to 7 Eastern, right?
11 to 8, Eastern.
11 to it, I'm sorry, yes.
And one should be in the...
Seven to 4 Eastern.
We can do 7 to 4, we can do 9 to 6. From my perspective, we'll check whatever is more convenient for him. It's fine with me. I can use him in both shifts while he's around.
The.
Okay, so probably you can have a word with Bunch directly and let us know how do you want to proceed.
Sounds good. Okay.
Okay.
And you have no issues with the genius ship being moved.
No, we don't.
Okay, sounds good.
Uh, other than that, I didn't have anything else, because again, Reza, we need Reza for the rest of this.
Key.
Was there anything from your side?
No, I guess the only thing that I wanted to know about is the training slots. So it is already said that this would be decided by Reza, so I'll wait for his response. And yeah, we are already working on Mansha's replacement. And Paxton is settling in fine. Jimmy is already taking care of things and Jasper.
Yes.
Thank you.
is already taking care of the costs and the customers. If you have any feedback for the engineers, please let us know.
Yes.
Okay, of course.
Okay. Torrin, anything from your site?
No, everything from my side is good. Our caddy has more of the day-to-day with all of your folks, but I always like to join to kind of make sure that I have an ear to the ground and know what's going on.
Yeah.
All right. Lee, anything you want to add?
I think he had probably understood that.
Nope, I'm good. I just wanted to say hello and check in.
Hello, hello.
The phone.
Right, Sarah.
I got it, and could be both.
Inquires.
Alrighty, so we'll meet next week. Until then, please take care. Thank you so much.
Kip.
Sounds good. Thank you for that. Appreciate it. Bye, guys. Bye.
Thanks, thanks, guys.
Blake.
Yeah, I will.